i was on my way back from walking
indiana this morning
and you know i walk him for about two
miles every morning
and i run
[Music]
uh i run the gamut
and i try not to listen to my headphones
and i really just try to think and
try to be in the moment of the walk and
all that [ __ ] you know
and so i
but in that runs a normal
you know hodgepodge smorgasbord of
emotions you know sometimes i'm mad at
people and
you know when you walk and you you you
tell them off
in your brain or i had a couple of those
conversations and
and then some conversations just about
you know in my own brain
just going over some jokes running
through all the regular emotions
um and the conversations you have with
yourself when you're out walking
i had been complaining in my own head
the last little bart
part of the walk
snowing i was having trouble getting my
feet i was tired i was hot i was
sweating but it was cold
i had been complaining about things that
in retrospect
i'm i'm a little ashamed that i was
complaining about
and i was coming up on this woman
and um you know indiana on the walks if
you have food in your hands
he's come before it he doesn't know you
and he doesn't give a [ __ ] about you but
he knows that's food
and so i just kind of veered off a
little bit and let her walk on the
sidewalk and i just moved over
a little bit to walk in the you know the
front of people's lawns and stuff and
she had a bag of like tacos
or not taco i don't know but had a bag
in her hand and i say hello to everybody
guys especially if it's just me and you
walking down the street it's like a
residential street and there's nobody
there like
i'm i'm saying hello
you know you don't you don't have to say
hello back so i'm walking around and um
she isn't
she's just like me really like you're
out in the morning
on a walk with your you know
and i said how you doing and um she said
good and when she opened her mouth i saw
that she had like
two two teeth like one on top one on the
bottom
and then like a bunch of halves and a
bunch of holes and
um
and uh
i said how you doing she said i'm doing
really good
and i said um i said well that's really
good she was yeah i got um i got two
barbacoa tacos in here and i said oh
that's nice
and there was because there's a little
taco truck down at the
end of the street she said i got two
barbacoa
tacos and i said that's nice and she
said
i'm trying to keep them warm because
it's you know it's snowing and [ __ ] it's
cold here
and i said yeah yeah i get it she said
um
i have one for me and
one for the woman who's letting me stay
in her back house because it's so cold
and i said oh she was yeah you know i'm
homeless
and then i i looked at her i'm like oh
yeah i usually see her right down here
she goes i'm homeless
and um i stayed out all night but i
think i got enough money to buy us both
a taco this morning
to buy us both a taco this morning
and uh she said i can't wait to share
this with her she's been so good to me
she's been so good to me and letting me
stay warm these last couple days
and man you know
like the things that i was worried about
and how happy she was and just the
gratitude she had for this woman
and how proud she was of herself
to be able to buy that taco for somebody
was just
was so overwhelming for me
which showed me so much that this is all
about perspective you know
and same for that woman who saw this
homeless woman down at
the end of our little spot here and
and saw her and knew it was cold and
said hey come you can come stay in my
back house and this woman
who obviously maybe she didn't want to
feel like that she was
was a homeless woman who didn't feel
like she wanted to feel like she wanted
to give back
she wanted to give back
she stayed out and begged or whatever
she
does to get money i'm assuming beg just
because i always see her
panhandling and uh
she stayed out
to pay this woman back for letting her
stay at her home man
and what the [ __ ] was i complaining
about
what have i done in the last
year of my life that's compared to
either thing that
either one of these two women did
the woman who let her stay and this
homeless woman who
knows more about life obviously than i
do
that she still felt it was important to
give back
and to be kind and to help her fellow
people you know
it was so moving she was so
proud of herself she was so happy she
was hustling guys hustling to make sure
those tacos were still
warm
for this woman she wanted to share that
with her so badly i
i know it shook me a little bit
it it shook it
it shook me a little bit
i don't know if it made me question
who i am but it sure didn't make me
question what i thought was important
but
i really felt like i needed to get that
out
to whoever needed to hear it but
you know i
it was
something i needed so
um yeah
i thought i'd share it with you it was
pretty crazy i so impressed with that
woman
you know and i and i think people like
that
come into your
life for a reason
you